[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
ladies and gents the new season of
fortnite arrives on tuesday march the
16th
and begins with a solo mission as we
fill the boots of agent johnsy
and end the zero point crisis storyline
to get ready for that
i'm back with a recap of everything we
went through in season five
so do me a favor drop a like if you'd be
so kind and think about using code
adamaru to support videos like this one
now sit your butt down for 10 minutes
and let's go through the last 15 weeks
week zero i know this is a weird place
to start but it's important
back when galactus arrived and thor iron
man and the other avengers gave him the
fight of his life
the key point of interest was the zero
point which once again was ruptured
just like it did back in chapter one for
the first time ever we were shown two
realities side by side and the zero
point affecting us on the island but
also in the real world too
causing an earthquake agent johnsy who
has been watching us for a very long
time now
suddenly sprang into life then the law
hit us
we found out agent jonesy has a boss who
sends him back into the loop
for three reasons stabilize the zero
point
reseal the bridge and not let anyone
escape
with that info jonezy enters the zero
point and joins
our world he also missed a warning that
the seven
may be watching
week one on the island we saw many
changes on day one of this new season
the cracked orb floating above the new
sand area was the main wow factor zone
especially as the mandalorian crash
landed nearby
but we also saw many other changes like
old pois returning
somehow both the der burger and pizza
pit restaurants
reappeared in their og spots from 2018.
over at the superstore it happened again
the original viking ship
appeared in its original island location
there's more
the dusty containers and even flush
factory returned
and to top it all off salty springs was
combined with tilted towers
to create salty towers a place for
sweats
to call home we never saw any answers
about this but a theory i personally
believe
is the convergence as the zero point
slowly combines both chapter one and
chapter two islands
causing these anomalies there was
totally new stuff too
four brand new pois arrived in season
five
a jungle biome named stealthy stronghold
housed
jurassic park like cages and gates but
this proved to be a misdirection
let's come back here soon a coliseum
appeared in the desert and south of that
was the butter barn which loki had the
best music
i've ever heard in a restaurant
finally for this opening week of the
season hunter's haven materialized
a group of homes for very different
people all of which could be found in
the battle pass
these were the guys agent jones had
recruited to stop anyone escaping the
loop
the buildings were filled with things
each hunter needed like a warrior's
shrine
a bonsai tree and pili in carbonite
fair enough hunters from different
realities was a theme of the season
and oh my word there was so much more to
come
[Music]
week two arrived and we learned the
hidden story of the season
firstly the emblems on the wall in
hunter's haven told us about the
existence
of the io the imagined order the same
organization we believe
agent jones is a part of and of course
those annoying troops working with
johnsy
who sprang up out of the ground to stop
us mid-match
linked to this we all discovered hidden
underground facilities at all the new
pois
which led to more io bunkers deep below
even stealthy stronghold had a modern
facility hidden under its ruins
some things sus was going down but we
had answers we just had to find them in
game
around the island were more npcs like
we've seen in previous seasons
but this time the npcs could speak
well sort of it was it was text based
strange things happened
ruckus could be eliminated and then
returned as a ghost-like figure
others could be recruited or bargained
with for supplies in ammo
but one of those was very different
bunker jonesy
this jonesy has retained his memories
from the days of the first island
he first confirms we are in a loop and
then tells us he was originally asked to
jump into the zero point
to see what happened luckily he survived
he was the first snapshot which in
layman terms
means when someone enters the loop they
are duplicated and that's why there are
so many versions of the same characters
around especially johnsy then came the
big stuff
bunker johnsy tells us there is a way
out of the loop his dialogue changed
over the season but the main things of
note
is that the reboot vans are the key to
escaping and midas is confirmed to be
yet
another snapshot a different midas came
back from the one who started the device
event
his clues became more cryptic over time
but for a quick bit of law
bunker jonesy has helped us out and
remember midas is still important to
this storyline
and speaking of midas also in week two
the fully complete golden storage in
lazy lake could be found in the basement
a golden midas toilet from season two is
here a golden vars
and even a solid gold grain the gnome
graham will be important again one day
i promise
[Music]
week three saw crimbo arrive at retail
row i actually forgot this season began
in december
the misfit bear came back luckily they
didn't come alive this year
up by the snow-covered weather station a
new easter egg could be found
a mysterious indestructible book lay
here
this was for the creator cipher pk who
from my research
i can tell you who makes a fortnight
video every 22 minutes
it's a fact and to round off the week
the final ever update to hot watch
arrived
turning this slow building erection into
a cafe
not what i was expecting but it's a
pretty cool chill area
for team thick week three's most
intriguing change saw the mandalorian
become the man to watch
as he collapsed his campsite next to his
crashed ship
and set up next to the coliseum he was
looking for something
and every update saw him get closer a
thing i adored was the footprints mandel
left behind
attention to detail let's check back on
him next time
a new npc joined the island this week
and sold us a brand new crimbo weapon
snomando made his home up by the snowy
mountains and left a confusing greenbelt
nearby
christmas continued to be a thing in
fortnight as more houses
got in the crimbo spirit and over at the
tree nursery
those trees were all gone again the
circle of life continues
oh and a quick note over by the house
where fake john wick is staying
you'll find rocket league decor again to
celebrate the new season of that game
and just like last time the rocket
league car is waiting to be driven
in the garage next door oh and um kratos
from god of war appeared this week
it was a damn strange week boy
[Music]
week four the snow fell on the island it
didn't cover the same stretch of land
this time around but christmas cheer was
here once again
the green belt near snomando became a
micro airport base
and stayed for the rest of the season
elsewhere other outposts popped up
bringing back planes into br oh and yes
another hunter arrived this time
via a refrigerator master chief from
halo is here
wow but that wasn't even the biggest
moment of the week this update
saw a rift open between worlds the power
of the zero point
and jones's rift sphere dragged michonne
and daryl from the walking dead
into fortnite the zero point was put
under extra pressure
and from this day forward it began to
crack more and more every update
week five arrived and so did another
rift portal this time to add even more
marvel characters
including black panther that trailer hit
me right in the fields
this week mando could be found by
pleasant park he's still searching for
something
week 7 sprang into life on january 13th
and took away all the christmas updates
the snow receded back to the mountains
and the trees at each poi
vanished the airplane spawn points
disappeared too
and a new variation to the coliseum
magically materialized
a flooded pit i got to admit my favorite
version of the colosseum was the llama
and crab belts
the big news of the week was up at
stealthy and many people's theories were
right
the predator's escape pod crash-landed
into the jungle biome
and noisy clicks and shouts of anger
became audible
luckily we didn't have to wait too long
for the next update it arrived
seven days later week eight he's here
he's finally here
the predator followed agent jonesy to
the island and became a roaming npc
at stealthy stronghold big preds was the
unlockable hidden skin for the season
and people old enough to have a clue who
that is rejoiced
the predator brought with him a stealth
gauntlet which allowed us to become
invisible for a brief period of time
if you're like me you wasted every game
trying out different emotes whilst
invisible
it was great fun to mark the arrival of
big preds a room at hunter's haven was
updated to make him feel at home
with his pro level gaming chair and
setup added as well as an armor stand
and a med kit nice touch the first
hunter here mandalorian
set up his campsite near salty towers
this week and seven days later he moved
it to the overlooking point at the zero
point
yep he's still searching for something
finally another rift portal appeared at
steamy stacks
dragging the energy from the zero point
once again and we all figured out pretty
quickly
it was for a terminator crossover that
zero point
really looks angry now
week 10 of chapter two season 5. this
week
v became available after hacking
fortnite's twitter account
she asked for help from drift in a place
we thought was lucky landing
that update never actually happened but
v and the fox clan
look to be key characters in the seasons
to come the biggest news this week was
that mando
has finally stopped searching after 10
weeks walking around the desert
he's found his new home a star wars
style cantina popped up
along with the new game mode mando's
bounty stormtrooper helms could be found
on spikes outside to let us know where
they stand in the galactic war
and inside a returning character could
be found jeff keely
the last time we saw him was during the
star wars crossover event
in 2019 so many characters and rifts
appeared in this week
a tron inspired portal appeared by the
lake and we also found
snake eyes from gi joe and the flash
from the dc universe
john d is pulling out all the stops to
locate hunters and fighters from
multiple dimensions
but each time the zero point is
harnessed it becomes more and more
unstable he must stop right now
right well hell no chun li ryu
and chun-li's thighs came to fortnite
and i couldn't be happier
week 11 it's valentine's week in
fortnight in which we could find love
chocolates and potions
under leviathan's head waiting for a
meal at a restaurant
fortnite is is just weird it's just
weird
week 13 came and went with only two
updates
but they were big updates the zero point
is now throwing a hissy fit
it's so angry and the most unstable
we've seen it all season but jonesy will
not stop calling for the cavalry
this week he grabbed ripley and the
xenomorph from the aliens franchise
in week 14 it was all about the zero
point it became more ferocious letting
out an energy force
every hour which as the week went on
went down to eight minutes
and then four minutes and now in week 15
it's only two minutes apart
the zero point is counting down to the
end of season conclusion
on march 16th we will play through the
final events of the zero point season
in what is described as an explosive
conclusion
it suggests we may even play as agent
johnsy in a solo mission
all we know right now is that reality
will change once again
but will the hunter become the hunted
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure
i'll see you all in season six
[Music]
you